moi aussi
j'avais peur de l'orage à ton âge
tu vas garder mais pas plus la mère que
je suis ton père
je ne m'étais jamais confié 1 personne
sur mon histoire
tu le sais très bien je te conduit à
l'orphelinat
interpellé
il ya plus faire cet enfant pour qu'il
s'attire les foudres de tout un village
sauf votre respect monsieur c'est pas
votre affaire
je vous propose de louer cet enfant
vitalis monsieur vitalis artistes
ambulants on connaissait déjà captivé
content là se nomme jolicoeur approché
enfants car le spectacle que nous allons
vous présenter reconnu pour être le plus
ordinaire de frost je t'aiderai un
emprunt pour chanter devant dijon en
effet
vous avez dit que j'arrive au vent mais
tu as trahi c'est normal au début tu es
un do ré mi
celui d'émouvoir suite entendeur
[Applaudissements]
mon maître ne m'avait pas menti j'aimais
chanter et je savais déjà que je ne
cesserai jamais de le faire si peu
d'occasions d'armes et fierté
on charge et mis ma mère et moi semble
avoir retrouver tes parents
trompez pas manquer vie
[Musique]
emmener les bleus bas
ce parti comme marielle
les foires mois
[Musique]